Bob: I-I still feel shook.
Mark: Yeah.
Wade: Heh.
Bob: Or "lit"...
Mark: No, not that one.
Bob: ...or swole, or something.
Mark: Woke.
Wade: Swole!
Bob: Woke.
Mark: You woke now, 'cause you're aware and you're-
Bob: I'm woke as fuck.
Mark: You're awake to the genitals.
*Mark popping his lips*
Bob: Ugh.
Mark: Anyway, hello everybody, my name is Markiplier and welcome to Giraffe's Volleyball Champion... ship *sigh* 2016.
*Bob & Wade laughing*
Mark: I can't do a single god-damn intro.
Bob (mocking): Champinion-chup!
Wade: Chup!
Wade: Ship!
Mark: It's been a long day because today we did all of the "meet people out in the park" kind of thing, and we just got done with Genital Jousting.
Bob: And McDonald's didn't give us like half our food.
Mark & Wade: Yeah, that's true.
Mark: So uh...
Bob: So... sponsor us McDonald's. And give us all our fucking food!
*all laugh*
Mark: But either way decided to have a palate cleanser with Giraffes Volleyball Championship
Bob (high pitched voice): It looks so cute!
Mark: It is cute, it's cute.
Mark: Alright, so we got this game because it looked adorable and cool and it- it looks like something that might be very difficult to do but at the same time rewarding.
Mark: Oh.
Bob: Woah, woah.
Mark: Hi, hey.
Bob: Woah, hey.
Mark: Hi.
Woahahahah!
Bob: 'Sup?
Mark: Hi, how's it going?
Mark: Oh, I forgot something.
*Laughter*
Wade: Woah.
Wh-wha?
Mark: Wha-? Did you say somethin'?
Bob: Wait... you over there?
Mark: Yeah.
Bob: What's going... what's going on?
Mark: Ooohhh.
Mark: Nothing.
*Wade giggles*
Bob: Wait! Come back!
Mark: Wha-! What's that?!
Bob: Ah, hang on.
Bob: Could you-?
Mark: Oh- hi.
Bob: He-
Mark: Ooohh-kay.
Mark: That's- I need personal space.
Bob: Baby, come back over, baby
Mark: No- ah- I-
Bob: Come over here, baby.
Mark: Um-
Bob: Come here, come here.
Bob: Come on.
*Mark quickly kisses*
Mark: Ohhh.
Bob: You don't gotta have your head up high.
You can be a little- a little... *shrinking sound effect*
Mark: Okay- alright, you know-
I'm just going to do this this once.
*Silence*
*Bob starts making gasping noises*
*Bob's gasping picks up speed*
Wade: This is a very different game than Genital Jousting.
Mark: You bout to-?
*Bob grunts*
Mark: Aw!
*continued grunts*
Mark: Sorry!
*more grunts*
Mark: Aw, my bad!
*Bob calms his grunting*
Bob: Sorry.
Bob: Ahhh...
Bob: That was good, baby.
Bob: No- wait- sorry, sorry!
Bob: Hang on- wait, wait, wait!
*failed kiss*
Bob: Wait, come here.
*They kiss again*
Bob: Okay see ya!
*they all laugh*
*claps*
Bob: What the actual fuck is happening?
Mark: I-I don't know.
Wade: I was wondering-
*Bob's laugh gets louder*
Mark: Is this the whole game?!
Bob: Is the resolution off? Is it just too-
outside the thing on the screen?
Mark: No, I don't- I think of-
Mark: Something is supposed to happen.
*Wade & Bob giggle like children*
Mark: Something's supposed to happen.
Bob: Oh my god!
Mark: There we go!
Mark: We just had a bug.
Mark: Oh, oooohhh, myyy gawd!
*Wade giggles*
*Mark attack noise*
*Mark's French laugh*
Mark: Oh they can't-
Bob: Hyup!
Mark: HAAaaa.
Mark: Aw fuckin'-
Bob: Spiked it bitch!
Mark: Oh my god.
*Bob wiggling noise*
Wade: Whoa-ho-ho!
*Mark slower wiggle noise*
*Mark's battle cry*
Bob: Hyuuuk!
Bob: Oh god!
Wade: I don't know if you've noticed, but I think you're-
Wade: something changes
Mark: HUAHAU!
Wade: whenever you score- I think
Wade: your neck or something-
Mark: YES.
Wade: I don't know.
Mark: GUUUU.
Bob: So that's what we were doing before.
Bob: We were all-
Mark: HEA-THE-GUGU!
Mark: You were just-
Mark: I-I mean
Mark: I appreciate the-
Mark: the depravity of that scene.
All: NOOO!
Bob: It goes through your legs?!
Mark: Through your legs!
Bob: God damn it!
Wade: I guess legs don't count.
Bob: Damn it!
Mark: OH!
Mark: I'll stay down here.
Why would I need to be up there?
*Bob attack sound*
Bob: Oh no.
Mark: Why do I need to be up there?
*Mark's baby noises*
Bob: Ball, ball, ball ball, hoh-
Mark: He-leedle leedle lee!
*confronting sounds*
*weird grunts*
*noises continue*
Wade: Oooohhhh!
Bob: Oh god! Jeez!
Mark: YES!
Bob: I went up fast steadily-
*Mark's weird noises*
*Bob joins in*
Bob: Yeah keep comin'- come over-
Mark: IT'S COMING!
Bob: Keep doin' that!
Mark: It's coming!
DAAAAAHHH!
DEH?
Mark: You like that?
*Bob rearing up sounds*
Bob: Gyup!
Mark: Dup.
Mark: Oh- heyyy.
Mark: Heyyy.
Mark: Dop.
Bob: OH JESUS!
Mark: WOW!
Bob: Oh my god!
Mark: You can get it under your neck and
release to
slide it down.
Wade: Holy...
Bob: HYUK-
All: Whoa!
Mark: Whoa, whoa!
*Mark attack noise*
Mark: Ohhh boy.
*Wade giggles*
Mark: It's that extra bouncy ball there.
Bob: Whatchu got boy?
Mark: Fuuuuckin'-
HUP!
Fuuuckin'-
Bob: O-oh god- oh-
*dual attack sound*
Wade: Oh!
Bob: Fuck! Ah shit!
*Mark grunts*
Bob: Ball. Ball.
*Mark giggles*
Mark: Uh-oh.
Bob: Ball, if we could-
BALL!
Mark & Wade: Awwww.
Bob: Fuckin'-! How the fuck was I supposed to fuckin'-?
*Mark making weird noises on each boop*
*Bob laughs*
Bob: Aww.
Mark: Alright.
Mark: You wanna go best of three?
Bob: Sure.
Mark: Best of three and then we'll trade off.
Mark: HA-DEDUHDUH!
Bob: Sllle-HIP!
Mark: SNORGEN!
Bob: Oh jeez-
Bob: Oh god!
*Mark evil giggle*
*wiggling noises*
Wade: Are you wearing a mask or are those just glasses?
Mark: I think it's a mask.
Bob: HWOOO!
Bob: TOUCH DOWNNN!
Mark: Da-geh-doo!
Bob: Aw shit-
Bob: Ah-
Bob: Nya-
Bob: Nyagh.
Bob: OH GOD!
*Mark starts laughing*
Bob: I'm so slow!
Mark: God, the spider legs.
Bob: I don't understand the
Bob: movement physics of the legs.
Mark: Alright, I'mma try and balance this on my head.
Mark: Ha, oh.
Bob: Oh!
Mark: Oh sorry.
Wade: Whop!
Mark: Ohh jeez.
Mark: LLLLLL-jeez-ums!
All: Owww.
Wade: Through the legs.
Mark: Haha, hehe.
Bob: When you get low, the legs are extra weird.
*Mark does mating call*
Bob: Hyah!
Bob: Aw yeah!
Wade: Oh, here we go again.
Wade: Bob's crazy serves.
Bob (Ethan voice): My crazy boys.
Wade: *giggles* No.
Mark: What is up my-?
Mark: KH-raazeh!
Mark: UAH!
Wade: Move your legs-
Bob: What?!
Bob: What the f-?
Bob: Wu? Wa?
Mark: Yeah, I know right?
*Bob continues to what is disbelief*
Mark: God, I'm a fuckin' wizard.
Mark: You ever wonder why my legs do these things?
Mark: BOINK!
Bob: Ah shit.
Bob: Huuah!
Wade: Whoo-oo!
Bob: Hyuuuah, gotcha.
Bob: Boink, got 'eemmm.
Mark: *gasps* That was an amazing serve!
Wade: Huuuaahh!
Bob: Daah shit. *laughs*
Bob: That was harsh.
Bob: Hyuh!
Mark: Ooohh, dee-duh, aaww, dee-duh, AAHH, fuck.
*Bob & Wade laugh*
Mark: Alright, hang on, hang on.
Mark: HA-da-aw fuck.
*Bob laughs*
Mark: Hup, there we go.
Bob: Oh no.
Wade: Oh boy.
Bob: OH GOD! *grumbles in defeat*
Mark: Yaaay!
*Mark making weird noises again*
Wade: I feel like this is Mark's revenge for Genital Jousting.
Mark: Handsome Giraffe Wins!
*continues noises*
This might be my favorite game that I've played, in a long time.
*Mark leedle noises*
Bob: This is really satisfying, in a lot of ways.
Mark: Dah, boink, dah, fuck.
*everyone laughs*
Mark: I was lookin' for- trying to do fancy.
Wade: Well this isn't too hard so far.
Bob: Wait, how can you ass right up to the edge of the screen and I can't?
Mark: You can't?
Bob: That's why it fell between me and the wall before.
Wade: Oh no, you can't.
Mark: Ohhh.
Bob: What the shit is that?!
Mark: Well it doesn't matter because apparently
Mark: I'm gonna fuck myself over.
Wade: Yeah, you can't go all the way over here...
*combatant grunts*
All: WHOA!
Bob: Wade's got the D...
...fense.
*mix of whoas and oohs*
Bob: Oh no.
Mark: Well yeah.
That would present a distinct disadvantage.
*Bob & Wade agree*
Bob: Yeah, like, what are you supposed to do now?
You can't fuckin-
There ya go, there ya go.
Get it on the head there.
Oh!
Wade: What did I do?!
Mark: You didn't
Mark: do it right.
Mark: Hut-dee.
Bob: Oh dear.
*Wade's weird noises*
Bob: It falls faster than you think.
*Wade switched his noises to attempt a beat*
Mark: Wow.
Bob: I could just-
Mark: That's a very pathetic dance.
Bob: I could just stare at the legs.
Wade: -grunt- WHOOOOHHHH!
Bob: The leg wobble.
Wade: WHOOOAAAH!
Bob: And be really satisfied
Bob: for a long time.
Mark: It's just a pleasant game to look at.
Mark & Bob: DUAAHH!
Bob: OOOOOH!
Wade: Whoo!
*continues whoos*
Bob: Especially-
Mark: You got lucky that time punk.
Bob: Especially the down-low
Wade: Maybe.
Bob: like wobble, it's too much.
Wade: Debabe.
Mark: Your mom got lucky last night, with me.
Bob: You guys need some hype giraffes in the background.
Wade: Okay.
*struggling noises*
Bob: Oh god.
Bob: Oh! Oh God! Oh jee-!
*Wade combatant grunt*
Wade: WHOA-HO!
Mark: Heeeeyyy.
Mark: Ho-tah.
Wade: Wuh-oh.
Mark: You're not gonna need to do anything else.
*Wade grunts back in a good effort*
All: Ohh.
Wade: I thought my body hit it.
*Mark hupt-dee herdy gurdy sounds*
Mark: AaaAAAhh.
Bob: *laughing* Mark mostly just scores on himself.
Wade: Nice job, buddy.
Mark: I'm just tryin' to be fancy.
Bob: I just need to let you- uh
Bob: shit talk.
Bob: That's al- that was my mistake.
*Mark giggles*
Bob: I tried to play too much.
Mark: Ulp-
Mark: You ready for this?
Wade: I think so.
Mark: Ya-deh-deyuh.
All: WHOOAH!
Mark: Doplenki.
Bob: Oh god.
Bob: Oh god!
Mark: Yeah, you can't come back.
Bob: OHHH shit.
Wade: I did.
*attack sounds*
Bob: Oh shit.
Mark: Just try to get it back!
Wade: EH!
Bob & Wade: WHOA-OA!
Bob: Oh! It's free shots!
Mark: AaaAAAhh.
Wade & Bob: OOOHHH!
*Wade continues to taunt*
Mark: Good thing it's best of three.
Bob: Again, again!
Mark: Good thing it's best of threeee.
Wade: Good luck.
Wade: I have a family of thr-
Mark: HUTDA DEE!
Mark: I don't care about your family.
Bob: I thought it was gonna go over. *laughs*
Mark: You suck dick.
Wade: Eyhch.
Wade: Eyu-pup.
Bob: Those trick shots though.
*Mark attacks valiantly as Wade struggles to fight back*
All: Whoaa.
*Wade pretends to be a noodle*
Bob: Did we take drugs or something?
Bob: I feel really loopy right now.
Bob: The- the unbelievable juxta"bition"-
Wade: Aw noooo.
Bob: juxtaposition of just having stopped
Bob: playing Genital Jousting,
Bob: and now playing THIS,
Bob: it's just like,
Bob: I don't know what life is anymore.
Mark: We have chosen a weird day.
*conflicting attack grunts*
Bob: No, it's just about the most
Bob: jarring programming we could have gone with
Bob: for our let's play session.
Wade: ECH!
Bob: This is so -whispered- amaze.
Mark: I-I think this one-
Mark: th-this particular game should be played
Mark: while extremely drunk and/or extremely high.
Wade: Both.
Mark: *mumbles* Extremely drunk.
Bob: You know what it reminds me of
Bob: a little bit with the music and the aesthetic?
Mark: Yeah?
Bob: Did you play Lovely Planet?
Mark: No, I didn't-
Bob: It was like a first person shooter
Bob: that was like, really really loopy,
Bob: and you just run around and shoot your love at enemies
Bob: to defeat them.
Mark: OH I DID!
Mark: Yeah.
Bob: And the music was a lot like this,
Bob: and you were just like,
Bob: whoo!
Bob: Pew, pew, pew!
Mark: What if we look it up and it's made by the same developers?
Bob: That woud be
Bob: mindblowing,
Bob: because it is-
Bob: it's got that similar vibe that I really like.
Wade: WHOO!
Mark: I mean, I really appreciate the- oh fuck.
*Bob laughs*
Mark: It's just so hard to predict when it's comin' down.
Bob: I know.
Bob: The- the- the physics is funky.
*Wade mumbles*
Mark: B-dee-dhee, trick shots.
Mark: I tricked ya up, you thought I was gonna do something and I wasn't.
Wade: Dooh. Woah.
Bob: Oh sweet Jesus.
Wade: I hate that stupid wall, too.
Bob: I know, I-I don't understand, that seems- that seems mean.
Bob & Wade: Ooohhh.
Mark: Gimme a chance.
All: OHhh.
Mark: Ah, lidle du.
Mark: What are you lookin' at?
Wade: You're rude, I think you better get back to serve.
Mark: I'm only rude to ugly people.
Wade: You're not brave enough to stay here the whole ti-
Wade: Oh fuck.
*Bob laughs*
Bob: I was really hoping it would just fall, that he was just like, fuck it, I wanna say this.
*All laugh*
Mark: Duaahhh.
Bob: Woahh, double trick shot.
Mark & Wade: WhoAAAhhhh.
Wade: Nice trick.
Mark: I'm up here, bitch.
Bob: Oh dear.
Mark: OHhbe.
*Mark laughs*
Wade: I thought my chest was gonna get it.
*Mark laughing*
Bob: Haha, you thought me had me, but you didn't,
Bob: you thought me had me. *laughs*
Mark: I'mma take this,
Bob: Me has me.
Mark: aaand bring it over to you.
Bob: Me ask me a question.
Bob: Ohh that chest bump though.
Mark: Is that a Walking Dead thing?
Mark: L'me ask you somethin'.
Bob: Yeah, that was our, uh-
Wade: Shane, uh, that was the Shane.
Bob: Drunk Minecraft Walking Dead.
Bob: L'me ask me somethin'.
Mark: L'me ask me somethin'. *laughs*
Bob: You thought you knew but you did not.
*All laugh*
Wade: III'mm lorry.
Bob & Mark: IIIMMM loorrrryyy.
Mark: Fucking hellll.
Bob: Wow, just fucked it right in there.
Wade: What are you gonna do now?
Mark: I'mma beat your, uh-
Mark: wife.
Wade: woAAAHHHH!
*Bob laughs*
Wade: Wowww.
*Bob & Mark laugh*
Wade: Good thing I'm just engaged.
Mark: I'm sorry, that's just too far.
Bob: Oh lord, that was- that was not what you meant to say I hope.
Wade: It was relatively far.
Mark: Not at all what I meant to say.
Wade: Oh whaaaaattt?
Wade: I appreciate that that wasn't what you wanted to say.
Mark: I'm sorry, I only meant to attack your skills, not your character.
Wade: Well, I mean, I'm kinda hurt, a little.
Mark: Sorry.
Mark: Nope, no, no.
Wade: Aw, why do you always win that head's up?
Mark: Because I am clearly better and thicker chested.
Wade: Bleh.
*grunting*
Bob: Woah.
Mark: Can you do- can you do nothing, huh? Nothing? Nothing?
Bob & Mark: Oh, ohhh.
Mark: Hwoah.
Mark: Fuck it. Fuck.
Bob: Huh, hey, huh.
Wade: Got you, didn't I?
Mark: You got nothing, ass... hole.
Wade: Got a point.
Bob: Wade.
Wade: Oh.
*Bob sighs in relief*
Bob: Falls faster than you think.
Wade: Yeah.
Bob: Falls fast.
Bob: It's coming at you.
All: Whoa!
Wade: Right there we go.
Wade: Come on.
Mark: Nope! Not today.
Bob: Oh my gosh, what a save though.
Mark: Hu- aargh!
Wade: No!
Bob: Ah!
Mark: Yes!
Bob: Oh my gosh.
Wade: Argh.
Mark: Yes...
Wade: Alright.
Bob: This game doesn't make me angry, it just makes me happy.
Mark: Yeah.
Bob: Even when- even when things happen that seem- seem unfair-
Wade: I'm not angry that this is going down this way.
Bob: Just feels so good.
Mark: Agh!
Bob: Sti- Stickbold absolutely made me angry.
Bob: I will say that.
Mark: Yeah.
Wade: *giggles*
Bob: I was fucking pissed.
Wade: I could tell.
Bob: Oh could you?
Bob: Was it me screaming like a psychopath that gave it away?
Mark: *laughing*
Mark: Ah, ah, ah.
Bob: Even when I won 'cause I actually did win one of those of those rounds.
Mark: What're you doing?
Wade: Trying to psych you and me out, apparently.
Mark: You- you won a lot, Bob.
Bob: I just got so mad.
Mark: I could te-
Bob: You couldn't help it.
Mark: It was really funny, though.
Bob: *laughs*
Mark: Can't wait 'til that video comes out.
Bob: You know- you know what those beautiful salmon
Mark: Eugh!
Bob: hills in the background remind me of?
Mark: No!
Wade: Yeah!
Wade: Woo!
Mark: How'd that go through my neck?
Wade: Uh I don't know.
Bob: Good job, Wade.
Wade: I felt like you did that to me a couple times.
Mark: Fucking bullshit.
Bob: They remind me of all the hills that we saw today while we were driving around LA meeting fans.
Mark: And also the hills on that last location, they're kinda-
Bob: Yeah, that-
Wade: Oooh!
Mark: Mmmm.
Bob: Oh, oh!
Wade: Eugh.
Bob: Oh!
Mark: Hyeuh.
Bob: Oh! There you go.
Bob: There you go, now you got it.
Bob: Oh Wade, oh Wade!
Mark & Bob: Oh Wade.
Bob: Holy jeez!
Mark: I'm gonna-
Bob: Oh God Wade!
Wade: *grunting*
Mark: I'm gonna- AHh!
Bob: Aw!
All: *laughing*
Wade: Oh man.
Bob: Oh my God.
Bob: All of that- all of that almost worked out.
Mark: Okay.
Bob: Oh!
Mark: Euh.
Bob: Oh yeah, oh yeah, you got him.
Mark: It all comes down to this.
Wade: I know.
Mark: Hah... ha.
Bob: Ouh, oh!
Wade: Woah!
Mark: Ha.
Mark: Ah.
Mark: *laughs*
Bob: *joins in*
Wade: Two inches at a top.
Mark: Hyehh!
Bob: Aw that- that block though.
*A lot of ahhs and oohs*
Mark: I know right? It's all gonna be a disappoint-
Wade & Bob: *cheers*
Mark: *disappointed noises*
Mark: Nooooo.... ahhhhh.
Bob: It makes me wanna applaud a lot.
Mark: Oh no man.
Wade: That was a well fought couple of matches.
Mark: Jeezums. Alright.
Mark: So now it's- it's- it's- it's Bob and Wade's turn.
Alright it's got to go around here.
It's Bob and Wade's turn.
Wade: It takes some getting used to being this side now.
Bob: Aw shit, alright there we go.
Wade: It's so nice being able to go all the way back to the wall.
Mark: I know right?
Mark: Oh no.
Bob: Not like this.
Wade: Nice save.
Bob: *Random rambling noises*
Bob: Ah shit! Why did I go up?
I'm bad at the up down controls, that's my big weakness.
Mark: Gotcha.
Bob: Eat shit.
Mark: *giggles*
Bob: Huh.
Bob: Nooo.
Mark: *Laughing*
Bob: God jeez.
Wade: Nice, nice moves.
Bob: You guys catch it on your neck. I can't do it.
Mark: Neck-ball coordination.
Bob: Ho ho nooooo.
*Mark laughing*
Bob: That was my trick shot and everything. God dammit.
Wade: Didn't work.
Bob: Yeah, score on yourself, do it for me.
Wade: Woah!
Bob: Do it. Thank you.
Mark: Ah, I meant to do that on purpose.
Bob: Tricksy tricksy bitch.
*Simultaneous reaction*
Wade: Wha... WHAT?
Mark: WOAH!
Wade: Wha...?
Wade: What was that?!
Bob: I don't know!
Wade: What was that bullcrap?
Mark: Wow!
Bob: I'm a wizard.
Mark: Apparently.
Wade: Well. Okay.
Mark: I'm still in shock.
Wade: Yeah.
Mark: I mean, I don't know why that's shocking when looking at all the necks and extendable legs, but...
that was shocking.
Bob: If you want to do something hard enough, it will happen.
Mark: Is that how it works?
Bob: That's what we want our character to do- FUCK!
*Through clenched teeth*
Bob: Do that hit with your head you bitch.
Wade: Hey.
Bob: Good game...
Wade: You too...
*tongue clicks*
*laughter ensues*
Bob: That's where your dick comes out right at the front of your chest.
Wade: Full... extension.
Mark: Ma-maybe those legs are just four dicks that he's walkin' with.
Wade: *hum in agreement*
Bob: KICK!
Wade: Could do better next time.
Wade: Oooh...
Bob: That's not what I thought was going to happen.
Bob: Oh jeez.
Wade: Woah.
Bob: Just came out- oap.
*silly noise party*
Wade: Ball's over there, ball's over there now.
(Bob continues noise party)
Bob: Oh shit, no no NO NOOOO!
Wade: Now we're back to this.
Bob: Guah nah I'm so fucked.
I'm so fucked GAHdddddddaaaaamn.
Mark: Volleyball sucks.
Bob: I don't know how to fucking play in that spot. NnnnnnnnnaileD IT!
Mark: Just waiting for the magical, transporting net ball to appear.
Wade: No, not again.
*simultaneous ohhhs*
Bob: Ohh the trick shot!
All: WWOAAHHHHH!
Bob: Oh God Oh No!
Wade: Hey, that was a great serve.
*Laughter*
Bob: *mocking* That was a great serve.
Wade: I don't like that.
Bob: *whining* Why didn't that go your way? *continues whining*
Wade: *over Bob's whining* You went through the net once. Give me a break.
Bob: That's my only point.
*Random noises*
Mark: Yaaaay.
Mark: Humble giraffe.
Mark: That was Giraffes Volleyball Championship 2016. That was a delightful game.
Wade: *agrees with Mark*
Bob: That was unbelievably pleasant.
Mark: I-I had no idea it was gonna be like that.
Mark: So, uh, yeah, thank you everybody so much for watching,
Mark: and we really hope you enjoyed that because we had a delightful time playing that.
Bob: I feel so good right now.
Mark: I think this is a free game, right?
Bob: It was free on itch.io.
Wade: Yeah.
Mark: It was like a pay your own way kinda game, I think we chipped in twenty bucks for it.
Mark: You guys don't have to pay anything, or you can pay something to the developer.
Mark: This is a really charming game. I like it a lot.
Mark: I think they could improve it and, um, add a lot more features to it and it could be a really cool experience.
Mark: So thank you everybody so much for watching, let us know what you thought down in the comments below,
Mark: check out their channels in the description, and as always we will see you in the next video. Buh-bye!